66 million years ago an asteroid longer
than Mount Everest his tall hurtled
toward the earth crashing into the Gulf
of Mexico
more than 75% of plant and animal
species including the dinosaurs vanished
it took over 4 million years for life to
flourish once again but the environment
was altered forever
so scientists were shocked when they
discovered another large impact crater
buried a kilometer under Greenland's
hiawatha glacier what was even more
shocking was the craters lack of erosion
which suggested the asteroid could have
made impact when humans were roaming the
earth to be certain that their find was
really an impact crater researchers used
ice penetrating radar to get a sense of
the shape of the bedrock underneath the
ice the radar revealed one telltale
characteristic a raised area in the
center where the ground would have
rebounded after the asteroid hit like
water struck by a stone further evidence
came from the sediment draining out of
the glacier itself shocked quartz grains
were discovered which could only be
formed by extraterrestrial strikes or
nuclear weapons it was indeed an impact
crater 31 kilometres in diameter that
makes it one of the 25 largest known
craters in the world though it is
smaller than the asteroid impact that
killed the dinosaurs and the Chesapeake
Bay crater the asteroid making the
Hiawatha crater would have needed to be
enormous to with a diameter of more than
1.5 kilometers scientists still aren't
sure how young Hiawatha is but it is new
enough that it is the only crater of its
size still visible to the naked eye at
least if you could see through the ice
evidence suggests it is between a
hundred thousand to twelve thousand
years old though it could also be
millions of years older if the impact
happened when Greenland was covered in
ice which is most of the past two
million years billions of tons of ice
would have vaporized in an instant
leading to an influx of fresh water into
the world's oceans just such an influx
may have happened about twelve thousand
eight hundred years ago helping to set
off a thousand-year glacial period
called the Younger Dryas but evidence
for such a flood remains inconclusive
when the asteroid did hit faraway
regions would have felt the impact
hurricane-force winds would have
engulfed the region and objects as far
away as a hundred kilometers would have
been leveled the next step is pinning
down precisely when this massive
asteroid arrived and then the search can
begin for other craters lurking beneath
the ice
[Music]